en ce moment on parle beaucoup de
changements climatiques et j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de faire une vidéo sur le
sujet le réchauffement climatique qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui on pense qu'il est
largement dû aux activités humaines
mais dans le passé la terre a déjà connu
des changements climatiques et notamment
une alternance de périodes de glaciation
la dernière elle s'est terminée il ya
seulement 12 milan est à son maximum la
calotte glaciaire qui recouvrait toute
l'europe du nord et une bonne partie de
la grande bretagne
pire il ya 700 millions d'années il ya
une énorme période de glaciation au
cours de laquelle la terre était
peut-être entièrement recouverte de
glace tout ça nous dit qu'il ya
évidemment d'autres facteurs que
l'activité humaine qui influencent le
climat
et parmi ces facteurs il ya des toutes
petites variations de l'orbité de la
terre autour du soleil
ces variations on les appelle les cycles
de milankovitch en l'honneur de
l'astronome serbe qui les a calculé pour
la première fois dans la première moitié
du 20e siècle
aujourd'hui on va voir ce que sont ces
cycles astronomiques et en quoi ils
peuvent influencer le climat
on va commencer doucement la terre
tourne sur le même en 24 heures et c'est
ça qui provoque l'alternance des jours
et des nuits mais elle tourne aussi
autour du soleil en 365 jours et c'est
ça qui provoque l'alternance des saisons
mais au fait vous êtes sûr de savoir
pourquoi il ya des saisons c'est pas
forcément si simple que ça à se
représenter il ya souvent des confusions
alors on va s'arrêter une minute dessus
l'orbité de la terre autour du soleil
elle se fait dans un plan imaginaire
qu'on appelle le plan de l'écliptique et
la rotation de la terre elle se fait
autour d'un axe imaginaire qui passe par
les deux pôles naïvement on a envie de
se représenter la kz2 rotation comme
perpendiculaire au plan de l'écliptique
un peu comme une grille qui tourne sur
une table l' axe de rotation n'est pas
perpendiculaire comme ça il est incliné
par rapport au plan de l'écliptique
d'environ 23 degrés demi et c'est ça la
clé des saisons parce qu'à certains
moments de l'année comme ici
l'hémisphère nord reçoit plus de soleil
que l'hémisphère sud
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'été mais six
mois plus tard c'est l'hémisphère sud
qui reçoit plus de soleil que
l'hémisphère nord et c'est ça qu'on
appelle l'hiver donc les saison sur
terre sont dues à cet angle de 23 degrés
et demi entre l' axe de rotation et le
plan de l'écliptique alors si la terre
et le soleil étaient seuls dans
l'univers
l'orbité de la terre elle changerait
jamais il n'y aurait pas d' influence
sur le climat
sauf que la terre et le soleil ils sont
pas tout seuls déjà il ya la lune qui
évidemment va influencer la terre mais
il ya aussi de bonnes grosses planètes
comme jupiter ou saturne qui bien
qu'elle soit située loin de nous vont
légèrement perturbé leur [ __ ] de la
terre et ce sont ces petites
perturbations qu'a calculé milankovitch
la première de ces perturbations et
concerne tout simplement cet angle
d'inclinaison je vous ai dit qu'il était
de 23 degrés et demi en fait ils varient
au cours du temps il oscille entre 22 et
24 degrés et demi alors c'est pas grand
chose sur cette animation j'ai beaucoup
exagéré le mouvement j'ai aussi beaucoup
exagéré sa vitesse puisque milankovitch
a pu calculer que l'oscillation complète
prend environ 41 mille ans et voilà le
résultat de son calcul un ici vous
pouvez voir la courbe qui montre la
valeur de l'angle qui oscille au cours
du dernier millions d'années qui nous a
précédés on voit la période
d'oscillation de quarante mille ans ce
mouvement périodique y joue sur le
climat parce qu'ils jouent sur
l'intensité des saisons si l'angle
d'inclinaison été nul il n'y aurait pas
de saison et plus l'angle est élevé plus
les saisons sont marqués alors ça change
pas la quantité totale d'énergie solaire
reçue par la terre mais ça change sa
répartition et comme le climat est un
système
complexe ça suffit à provoquer des
changements climatiques notamment les
périodes où les saisons sont peu marqués
vont plutôt favorisé les glaciations
parce que les été relativement doux
permettre le maintien des calottes
glaciaires la deuxième perturbation que
milankovitch à étudier c'est ce qu'on
appelle la précession je vous ai dit
qu'il y avait un angle entre l' axe de
rotation de la terre et le plan de
l'écliptique mais cet axe
il a aussi une direction en ce moment le
pôle nord ils pointent dans la direction
du soleil mais cette orientation elle
varie très lentement avec le temps alors
c'est un mouvement qui est pas très très
simple à visualiser mais tout à l'heure
j'ai fait la comparaison du mouvement de
la terre avec celui d'une toupie et ben
en fait la terre se comporte bien comme
une toupie mais une toupie à qui on
aurait mis un petit choc
vous avez peut-être déjà vu ça quand on
perturbe une toupie elle se met parfois
à s'incliner et avoir un lent mouvement
de rotation de son axe c'est ce qu'on
appelle la précession et c'est
exactement ça qui se passe avec la terre
lac s'est incliné et il subit une
rotation lente milankovitch à calculer
le rythme de cette rotation et il a
montré qu'elle se faisait avec des
cycles de 20 à 30 mille ans je vous ai
dit qu'en ce moment au mois de juillet
le pôle nord pointent dans la direction
du soleil est bien dans environ dix
mille ans ce sera l'un verse ce sera le
pôle sud qui pointera vers le soleil et
à ce moment là le mois de juillet sera
devenu la saison chaude de l'hémisphère
sud et la saison froide de l'hémisphère
nord dernières variations calculé par
milan kovic l'excentricité de l'orbiteur
alors qu'est ce que c'est on se
représente souvent les planètes comme
tournant en cercle autour du soleil
mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai en
général leur mythe d'un corps autour
d'un autre c'est pas un cercle c'est une
ellipse et le corps autour duquel se
fait la rotation n'est pas au centre
mais sur un des deux foyers de l'ellipse
la trajectoire d'une planète autour du
soleil peut être plus ou moins
elliptique et on caractérise ça avec un
nombre compris entre 0 et 1 qu'on
appelle l'excentricité quand
l'excentricité est zéro la trajectoire
est un vrai cercle est ici on peut voir
ce que c'est qu'une orbite avec une
excentricité de 0.5 et 0,75
vous voyez que quand leurs beats et
excentrique une planète sera pas
toujours à la même distance du soleil
l'exemple extrême c'est celui des
comètes la comète de halley par exemple
qui revient tous les 76 ans elle tourne
autour du soleil avec une excentricité
de 0,97 c'est à dire une orbite
elliptique extrêmement allongée quand
elles arrivent très proche du soleil
c'est là qu'on peut la voir
et ensuite elle tourne autour et repart
pour un voyage de 76 ans devant nous
l'orbité de la terre elle à une
excentricité très faible 0,017 c'est à
dire qu'elle est quasiment circulaire
fait pas une grosse bêtise si vous la
dessiner en cercle mais cette
excentricité elle varie très légèrement
au cours du temps elle passe de
quasiment zéro à 0,06 alors c'est pas
grand chose mais ça une légère influence
sur l'intensité des saisons plus
l'orbité est excentrique plus sacré des
variations dans la répartition du
rayonnement solaire au cours de l'année
l'évolution de l'excentricité elle est
un peu compliqué mais milankovitch il
avait calculé et la voici sur le
derniers millions d'années qui nous
précèdent et on voit qu'elle se produit
avec des cycles d'environ 100 millions
si on combine les trois perturbations
calculé par milan corovic on comprend
que ces variations peuvent avoir une
influence sur le climat terrestre
et encore une fois c'est pas tellement
la quantité totale d'énergie solaire
reçue qui change mais c'est sa
répartition et donc l'intensité des
saisons donc si on croit la théorie de
milankovitch le climat sur terre et
notamment les périodes glaciaires ont dû
varier avec des périodes proche de celle
qu'il avait calculé c'est à dire 20
mille quarante et un mille et cent mille
ans sauf que c'est bien gentil cette
théorie mais comment on fait pour
vérifier on n'était pas là il ya cent
mille ans pour mesurer le climat
eh ben on creuse dans le seul on peut
trouver des indices qui nous renseigne
sur les climats passés
vous avez peut-être que les roches
calcaires elles sont majoritairement
issus de l'accumulation de coquillages
et de squelettes d'organismes marins qui
se déposer au fond des mers eh bien ces
coquillages sont principalement fait en
carbonate de calcium caco3 et danse
carbonate de calcium il y a des traces
du climat passé la raison c'est que
l'atom d'oxygène comme la plupart des
autres at home
il existe sous différentes formes il ya
notamment l'oxygène 16 c'est le plus
courant 99 8% des atomes d'oxygène et
l'oxygène 18 beaucoup plus rare
seulement 0,2 pour cent et de même que
le taux de carbone 14 peut nous
renseigner sur l'âge d'un objet le taux
d'oxygène 18 nous renseigne sur le
climat qui régnait à l'époque où la co
qui s'est formée
plus le taux d'oxygène 18 est élevé plus
il faisait froid et plus la calotte
glaciaire était importante et en
creusant comme ça dans les roches
calcaires à différents endroits et à
différentes profondeurs
on peut remonter aux climats passés ce
que vous voyez ici c'est une courbe qui
montre l'évolution de l'oxygène 18 est
donc en quelque sorte de l'évolution de
l'extension de la calotte glaciaire pour
le dernier million d'années qui vient de
s'écouler et voyez que cette courbe elle
subit aussi des oscillations et quand on
analyse mathématiquement ces
oscillations on constate qu'elles
correspondent exactement aux
oscillations de 20 min 41 me
et cent mille ans dont on vient de
parler c'est à dire que dans le passé le
climat a bien varié suivant les cycles
astronomique qui avait calculé
milankovitch le seul problème pour lui
c'est que la confirmation de sa théorie
elle a dû attendre les années 70 à peu
près quinze ans après sa mort eh ouais
la science c'est parfois ingrat si vous
voulez voir de vos yeux ces oscillations
climatiques reflétée dans la roche il ya
quelques endroits de la terre où on peut
les observer un des plus chouettes un
endroit pour les voir c'est en sicile
c'est une formation qu'on appelle ce cas
la dei turquie l'escalier des turcs
on le voit très bien une alternance très
régulière de strates géologiques
ici on voit d'autres strates du même
genre c'est toujours en italie mais en
fait ce genre de structure périodiques
on les retrouve à différents endroits de
la planète des perturbations
astronomique gravé dans la roche
c'est pas beau ça alors il existe une
autre source qui nous confirme que dans
le passé le climat a bien varié suivant
les cycles de milankovitch ce sont les
carottes de glace est par exemple la
célèbre carottes de vostok en
antarctique dans ces carottes ce qui
nous renseigne sur le climat passé c'est
un autre élément chimique le deutérium
le deutérium c'est ce qu'on appelle un
proxy c'est à dire que ce n'est pas une
mesure directe de la température mais
c'est une mesure dont on pense qu'elle
est bien corrélé avec la température qui
régnait à l'époque la courbe que voyez
ici représente l'évolution passée du
taux de deutérium dans la carotte de
glace de vostok comparé à la courbe de
tout à l'heure sur l'évolution de
l'oxygène 18 dans les sédiments calcaire
et vous voyez que là aussi on retrouve
les périodicités de milankovitch alors
même si ça n'explique pas tout et qu'il
existe certainement d'autres phénomènes
en jeu
et puisque je vous parle de la carotte
de glace de vostok sont obligés de
mentionner autre chose dans ces carottes
on trouve aussi des bulles qui ont été
emprisonnés à l'époque où la glace s'est
formée et ses bulles elles nous
permettent de remonter à l'atmosphère
qui régnait à l'époque et notamment au
taux de co2 dans l'atmosphère
hélas si je trace l'évolution de la
concentration en co2 en parallèle de
l'évolution de la température
tanin elles sont parfaitement relier le
lien entre co2 et climat là ça vous
rappelle rien ouais sauf que si on y
regarde de près dans les données de la
carotte de vostok on voit que
l'augmentation de co2 elle suit toujours
l'augmentation de température elle se
produit environ 800 ans après ça veut
dire que pour ce qui s'est passé dans le
passé ça n'est pas l'augmentation de co2
qui a été à l'origine de l'augmentation
de température et de toute façon on l'a
dit les changements climatiques
l'origine ce sont les cycles
comme itx alors ces deux courbes vous
pouvez les retrouver notamment dans le
documentaire de al gore sur le
changement climatique vous savez une
vérité qui dérange
il a toute une mise en scène assez
spectaculaire et il sous-entend que le
parallélisme de ses courbes montre
l'influencé du co2 sur le climat
- et c'est évidemment un mauvais
argument puisque dans le cas de la
carotte de vostok au départ à la
causalité elle est dans l'autre sens
c'est l'augmentation de température qui
a initié l'augmentation de co2 et je lui
en veux d'avoir raconté ça comme ça et
d'avoir utilisé ces données de la
carotte de vostok pour soi-disant
prouver que le co2 était à l'origine du
réchauffement climatique qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
parce que même si on peut dire que
c'était pour la bonne cause c'est un
argument qui est scientifiquement
incorrect et évidemment les climato
sceptiques ont retourné le truc à leur
avantage en disant vous voyez bien c'est
pas l'augmentation de co2 qui provoque
l'augmentation de température celle
inverse
oui sauf qu'en fait l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre 1 on peut avoir une augmentation
de température qui provoque une
augmentation de co2 c'est ce qu'on voit
dans la carotte de vostok même si on
comprend pas forcément très très bien
quel est le mécanisme est à son tour
l'augmentation de co2 peut provoquer une
augmentation de température c'est le
principe de l'effet de serre et au total
on a ce qu'on appelle une rétroaction
positive dès lors qu'un phénomène qui
s'auto amplifie alors heureusement ce
qu'on voit malgré tout dans les données
du passé c'est que le climat sur terre
il n'a pas dégénéré en un réchauffement
sans fin ça veut dire qu'il existe
peut-être des rétroaction négative qui
vont venir tempéré le phénomène et ça
veut dire aussi que les cycles
astronomiques sont suffisamment forts
pour venir contrer ces rétroactions
positives
enfin bon ça prend quand même des
milliers d'années un bon dans tous les
cas le climat assez complexe et c'est
pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas tout
qu'il faut forcément foncer dans le mur
pour ceux qui voudraient en savoir plus
je les renvoie à ma vidéo sur le
réchauffement climatique
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo pour
ceux qui voudraient en savoir plus comme
souvent j'ai écrit un billet de blog
dans lequel je donne pas mal de détails
supplémentaires sur les cycles de
milankovitch l'oxygène 18 et puis un
certain nombre de problèmes qui sont pas
résolus aujourd'hui sur les liens entre
les glaciations le climat et les sites
l'astronomie retient comme toujours
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaînes vous pouvez
retrouver les
la chaîne sur facebook twitter et vous
pouvez aussi me soutenir sur tipi merci
beaucoup à tous ceux qui me soutiennent
comme c'est l'été je vais prendre un
petit peu de vacances conclure à un peu
moins de vidéos pendant les prochaines
semaines j'essaierai quand même de vous
en poster une ou deux sous un format un
petit peu plus léger et puis dans tous
les cas on se retrouve à la rentrée je
peux déjà vous annoncer le sujet de la
vidéo de la rentrée sera la gravité
quantique à boucles
merci à bientôt